KINGS ARE 2-7-2.
I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S ANYBODY
IN THEHOT, NOT THE
BEST SHOT IN THE WORLD BUT THEY
KEEP THE ATTACKTION TO TONIGHT'S
GAME.
LOOKS LIKE IT'S GOING TO HAVE TO
GO THE REST OF THE
DURZI DODGES, CARRIES THE PUCK
IN THE ATTACKINGDUMBA AROUND TH,
ZUCCARELLO PICKS IT UP FOR, MASS
FOR THE WILDTIC
IMPROVEMENT.
YOU KNOW IF THAT DOES IF YOU ARE
TO FORWARD NERVY
CERTAINLY HELD ON, NO REBOUND,
NO LOOSE OTHER
>> Alex: HERE IS DURZI, OVER
THE LIEN, AND KOPITAR FINALLY WA
FACE-OFF.
>> Alex: 1 OF 4 MINNESOTA
GOLDEN G G
MINNESOTA NET, I'LL PASS OFF THS
SKATES.
DOUGHTY CHOP LOW, STUFF IN THE T
DIDN'T WORK.
STRENGTH.
ACROSS ICE, MOVING -- ATTACKINGL
THE WAY ACROSS FINDS THE OPEN
MAN.
YOU CAN SEE THEREBY THE
SHOT, HITS A STICK ON T MESSAGEM
PUBLIC RELATIONS, THE KINGS
LOWER
BROWN.
NOTHING HAS BEEN CLEANED NOW. SA
CHANGE DIR.
ONE OF THE BEST SHOOTERS, HE
KIND OF FLUBS IT
ES IT OVER..
>> Alex:
DANGLES, SHOOTS, SAVE, HE LOOKS
ATTACK, BOUNCES
IT
BROKEN AUTOMATIC SITUATION,
KAPRISOV CUE. LOOSE PUCK AND
IT
THE PUCK TO ATHANASIOU,
BREAKAWAY, STOPPED BY
LATE.EPT OFF THE LINE AND
KEPT OUT OF THE GOAL!
QUICK HAS THIS